I'll be honest with you this is not Mars
but it's one of the closest simulations
we've got the Mars yard at NASA's Jet
Propulsion Laboratory in Pasadena
California
this is where NASA tests out models of
its Rovers before they get sent to the
Red Planet and over there
it's where necessary is it can learn to
drive one we have the Marsha which is
made of a few things some of them are
rocks that we actually take to a lab to
cook and ensure that they have the exact
same compositions and we bring it to the
Mars here other rocks are actually not
the same composition but the color is
the thing or the texture is the same and
the same thing with descent we bring
sands from specific areas so that the
color and the texture matches out here
in the Mars yard there's not just that
simple model I win that hangeth well
it's not really a model of curiosity
it's a full-size physical twin it's not
quite all the electronics and there's no
plutonium but it's close enough to
figure out what to do in tough
situations all the instruments all the
mechanisms that we have plus additional
simulations we put it all together and
we integrate it right here with like 80
to 90% is probably the same thing we
have on Mars there's a few things that
aren't for example the wheels themselves
the gravity is different on Mars so you
don't want to have the exact same
thickness of material on the ones on
earth otherwise you're going to break
them very easily and he's not going to
represent what actually happens on Mars
so the intent is try to dry run
everything that we can with this one try
to simulate it and then go for it on
Mars driving a rover comes with a
strange problem a time lag that
depending on where Earth and Mars are in
their orbits is anywhere between four
minutes and 24 minutes this is not a
case of just grabbing a joystick and
powering forwards there is a lot of
planning involved because if you break
that Rover there are no spare parts and
no second chances I've been dubbing
robots for since ur 2004 so 13 years out
I'm the person that has driven the most
high kilometers on Mars only 16 we can
go from beany low level commands that
say apply 5 volts to a model after a
command of saying go there and avoid all
the obstacles that are in between the
vehicle not only has a software onboard
who control the movement but now most
importantly has software to determine if
something bad is happening every day we
use the camera so to take pictures the
images left area so we can reconstruct
the 3d terrain from those pictures we
can determine what activities that we
can do at that location and the way it
is are safe to drive on curiosity we
have about 20 people that are certified
to drive the vehicle we have a different
size different comfort levels in terms
of risk or being so that we are scared
off some of us are particularly scared
of sand steep slopes it depends on what
problems you had when you were driving
every single day that we are going to
spend with the rover on a specific site
it's very important for us to test as
you fly and what I mean with that is as
much as possible do it here because you
don't want to be surprised when you try
to mark thanks to over team at the Mars
yard and Jet Propulsion Laboratory pull
down the description for more about them
and their missions